yesterday marked the 21st anniversary of
the September 11th Terror attacks
growing up in New York just north of the
city I remember the day vividly my
mother was in the city that morning as
usual for work and she saw the first
Tower fall from a train platform uptown
everyone knew people who died or at
least knew people whose friends or
family members had died we all knew
people who just barely made it out
people who who should have been there
and weren't there people who made it out
of downtown even out of the World Trade
Center walking miles and miles to get
out of the city many covered in dust and
debris some people would talk about it
most people I know who were there never
talk about it I don't judge either way
how people react to this singular event
in American history especially if they
had any association with it or were
close to it that's for them to process
there is one reaction
to the 9 11 attacks
that is unacceptable that is the
absolute lowest of the low as scummy As
It Gets that is to use the anniversary
of the attack to score some stupid cheap
political point on your opponents and so
of course the libs came out in full
force yesterday to do it Dean Obadiah
obadala he is a talking head on CNN he
tweeted Out quote terrorists are
terrorists be they bin ladens Al-Qaeda
or Trump's Maga time to hold Trump
accountable
Trump's Maga by the way not just Trump
's Maga that is to say Trump supporters
Trump voters that is to say half the
country half the country according to
this CNN contributor pretty mainstream
voice All Things Considered
Trump supporters half the country are
the same as Al Qaeda which is to say
that half the country is deserving of
death
now if it were just some CNN guy
mouthing off that would be one thing but
it wasn't Hillary Clinton the Former
Future president of the United States
former first lady U.S senator Secretary
of State
said basically the same thing I feel
grateful that we were able to come
together as a country at that really
terrible time we put aside differences I
wish we could find ways of doing that
again we rebuilt New York we have done
our best to take care of the
families that lost so much on that
terrible day and we have also I think
been reminded about
how important it is to try to deal with
extremism of any kind especially when it
uses violence to try to achieve
political and ideological goals
so I'm one who thinks that there are
lessons still to be learned from what
happened to us on 9 11 that we should be
very aware of uh during this time in our
country and the world's history
she's a little subtler than the CNN guy
but there's no question that she's
talking about us the libs use the phrase
extremism as a sort of synonym for
conservatism or republican politics
she's taken many cheap shots at us
conservatives she's insinuated that
we're terrible awful threats to the
Republic and that the left shouldn't be
civil with us
now she is obviously comparing us to the
9 11 terrorists and it wasn't just her
the sitting vice president Kamala Harris
was asked to compare Al Qaeda to alleged
domestic Terror threats posed by Trump
supporters and she did
we're at the 21st marking if you will of
the September 11th attacks yeah this was
a foreign terrorist attacking our
democracy attacking this country we're
now as a nation battling a threat from
within is the threat
equal or greater than what we faced
after 9 11.
that's an interesting question
um I have held many elected offices as
District Attorney General senator now
Vice President and there's an oath that
we always take
which is
to defend and uphold our constitution
against all enemies foreign and domestic
and
um we don't compare the two and the oath
but we know they both can exist and we
must defend against it so as usual she
says nothing explicitly but by accepting
Chuck Todd's premise that conservatives
are akin to Al-Qaeda terrorists she's
she's entertaining the comparison
Chuck Todd saying you know now we Face a
real domestic threat you know from those
nasty awful right Wingers and isn't it
it's kind of the same as Al Qaeda right
because wow really interesting question
no it's not an interesting question she
should have said Chuck that's disgusting
I reject the comparison outright sure
the Republicans drive me nuts but
they're not the same thing as Osama Bin
Laden but you can't do that because the
libs view us as the same thing as Bin
Laden not to be outdone sitting Democrat
Senator Mark Warner came right out and
said that conservatives they're not even
a comparable threat they are a greater
threat to America than the sort of
people who knocked down the Twin Towers
I remember as most Americans do where
they were on 9 11. I was in the middle
of a political campaign and suddenly the
differences with my opponent seemed very
small in comparison and our country came
together and in many ways we defeated
the terrorists because of the resilience
of the American public because of our
intelligence community and we are safer
better prepared the stunning thing to me
is here we are 20 years later and the
attack on the symbol of our democracy
was not coming from terrorists but it
came from literally insurgents attacking
the capital on January 6. so I believe
we are stronger I believe our
intelligence Community has performed
remarkably I think the threat of Terror
has diminished I think we still have new
challenges in terms of nation
state challenges Russia and longer term
a technology competition with China but
I do worry about some of the activity in
this country where the election deniers
the Insurgency that took place on
January 6th that is something I hope we
could see that same kind of Unity of
spirit
they're calling us terrorists okay and
it's not just some Fringe people it's
contributors on established liberal news
networks that's not just the
commentators it's prominent Democrat
politicians it's sitting Democrat
politicians it's the vice president it's
a U.S senator this just a little over a
week after the sitting U.S president
called us all fascists who pose an
existential threat to the country by our
very existence okay by our very presence
here they're accusing us of a capital
offense
because the libs don't just disagree
with us and they don't just want to
persuade us whether you want to believe
it or not and I think we don't want to
believe it we don't want to accept this
reality but you listen to the words that
these people are saying these people are
saying that they want us dead I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday it's from Vinnie
Vinnie Durham who says I am actually
shocked that Michael has never watched
Peppa Pig he would have loved it I would
have loved it but now they are turning
the freaking pigs gay they turned the
freaking Frog's gay some years ago Alex
Jones observed it now they are turning
even the British pigs gay and so so much
for Peppa Pig we need an alternative
what can I say that's what we need all
right we the culture is breaking
when things in your home break you're
going to want to have American Home
Shield right now go to ahs.com Knowles
we could all use some peace of mind when
it comes to staying on budget right now
that is why American Home Shield exists
as a member you know your home budget
Insanity are covered they offer a choice
of three great plans to help cover the
cost of repair or replacing parts of
major home systems and appliances no
matter their age if American Home Shield
cannot repair the covered item they will
replace it American Home Shield members
get more more coverage options and fewer
exclusions from HVAC systems and
plumbing to kitchen appliances their
plans help protect parts of up to 23
essential home systems and appliances
you get Electronics coverage available
for an unlimited number of eligible
items such as smart watches flat screen
TVs and more
other options include roof leak repair
and Pool and Spa coverage coverage
available no matter how old your systems
and appliances are plus right now they
are offering an exclusive 50 bucks offer
our listeners Keep Your Home up and
running and budget on track with
American Home Shield right now take 50
off their most comprehensive plans ever
go to ahs.com Knowles to save 50 bucks
ahs.com for 50 bucks off any Plan
American Home Shield be sure with the
shield service fees limitations and
exclusions apply see plan for details so
to follow the line of argument
the libs are saying that because
conservatives
objected to some of the changes to the
election system the major changes to
election system right before the 2020
election we are just like the people who
knocked down the Twin Towers and hit the
Pentagon that's what they're saying the
the issue that they're the the thing
that the conservatives did that they are
taking issue with is that we raised any
questions about the 2020 election that
makes this election deniers which makes
us insurgents which makes us terrorists
that's what they're all saying
and then
a Democrat Congressman Vicente Gonzalez
at the very same time in the very same
breath
accuses the GOP of stealing elections
and here's here's his reasoning here's
his evidence that the GOP stole an
election
like the values of our community but
only we can change that
they stole that last election they spent
3 million dollars to our 250 000 when
they campaign for two years and they
still only won by less than one percent
so the way to turn this around is
getting out and vote so folks thank you
for being out here let's get everyone
excited
thank you so much
so according to this Democrat
Congressman the GOP stole an election
this would be the election of Myra
Flores who beat uh representative Dan
Sanchez in a special election uh the the
reason that the Republicans stole it
is uh because they won
that's why when when the Republicans win
that is evidence that they stole it
because the Republicans are never
supposed to win because we have a
thriving democracy and so if one of the
two parties ever wins then that's an
attack on our democracy because by our
democracy they mean a one party
totalitarian system that marches
inevitably toward Progressive liberalism
that's the argument now you might say
Michael they're contradicting themselves
they call us terrorists when we raise
questions legitimate questions about
elections and then they raise
illegitimate questions about elections
and accuse us of stealing things with no
evidence whatsoever right it's not about
principle there is no principle here
okay it's just about power and the
lesson the takeaway for conservatives
here is to stop entertaining it to stop
trying to meet in the middle and find
some conciliatory middle ground and say
actually you know the Democrats have a
point Donald Trump really shouldn't talk
a certain way and actually Democrat you
have to give it to them you don't you
don't have to hand it to them they don't
have a point they expressly don't have a
point they're not really making
arguments they're just wielding power
against you who they consider to be a
terrorist you who they think are
committing a capital offense and by your
presence pose an existential threat to
the country you who they want to kill
they are telling you that in their own
words you do not have to hand it to them
I wish we could communicate better in
this country when you want to
communicate with your customers you got
to check out Podium right now go to
podium.com Knowles a lot of people hate
calling a business and would much rather
just send a quick message if you're
running a business and the only way to
get in touch with you is a phone number
you might be losing people Podium gives
businesses the tools to compete with the
convenience offered by bigger businesses
or huge companies like Amazon from
Healthcare Providers to Plumbers over
100 000 businesses are texting with
customers through Podium customers love
the convenience businesses love the
results one car dealer sold a fifty
thousand dollar truck in just four text
messages with podiums all in one inbox
you can do even more than just chat get
more online reviews by sending an easy
to use Link collect payments fast from
anywhere and send marketing campaigns
that actually get a response all by
sending a quick text see how Podium can
grow your business watch a demo today at
podium.com Knowles that's podium.com
slash Knowles podium
let's grow
the libs are so Brazen these days they
feel that they don't really need
arguments
the the mayor of New Orleans really
exemplified this I I
in a way I do have to hand it to this
lady not for any of the political
arguments she's making but just for her
boldness and temerity in making them the
mayor of New Orleans just got caught in
a political Scandal because she's buying
herself very expensive travel okay she's
buying herself first class travel New
Orleans is not the wealthiest city in
the world this This Woman's supposed to
be a public servant she doesn't need to
be flying first class and so she's asked
if she's going to reimburse the the
difference for the first class tickets
and this woman comes out there she says
how how dare you even raise that
question
all expenses incurred doing business on
behalf of the City of New Orleans will
not be reimbursed to the City of New
Orleans one thing is clear I do my job
and I will continue to do it with
distinction with dignity and integrity
every step of the way and so that's what
I'll have to say on that you're saying
that I'm a little bit corrupt but what
I'm saying is I do a great job so that's
that so that's it and she went on this
is my favorite part of the quote I can't
find a video clip of it anywhere but it
is being reported in multiple Outlets
quote as the mother of a young child
whom I live for I am going to protect
myself by any reasonable means in order
to ensure I am there to see her grow
into the strong woman I am raising her
to be
here's the punch line
anyone who wants to question how I
protect myself just doesn't understand
the world black women walk in
wait wait wait wait wait so you're
you're telling me that you're buying
yourself fancy first class tickets at
the taxpayer expense taxpayers of the
poor City that you're the mayor of
and then when you get called out for it
you're saying it's because you're a
black woman and black women can't fly in
coach
black white men can fly in coach but
black women you see it's too dangerous
to fly back there with those filthy Hoy
polloi oh could you imagine oh could you
imagine if it were a black woman in a
middle seat oh it would the risk would
simply be too high so you understand
this lady has to fly first class she has
to get some free glasses of champagne
for her safety it's always a threat it's
always a threat to their lives anytime
that that there's someone that they
don't like exercising any kind of power
anytime they don't get their way on the
left they say it's a threat
it's a threat I feel unsafe
when a conservative comes to a college
campus to give a lecture they say no I
feel unsafe we got to cancel the
conservative
when it when
regular old Americans vote for Donald
Trump they say no I feel unsafe they're
insurrectionists they're terrorists we
gotta and now This Woman's saying nah
sorry when you question my luxurious
expenditures at the taxpayer dime no I
feel unsafe sorry
black I'm a black woman here's my trump
card I'm a black woman shut up now
look it's working for her she gets to
fly first class she doesn't really get
questioned
this is how identity politics Works in
America
he claimed to be a member of an
aggrieved minority you can do whatever
you want you don't have to answer for a
damn thing
you don't have to make any arguments
this is why there is such a currency to
victimhood especially to racial
victimhood that everyone's trying to
claim it and when they can't claim it
because
there is there is no anti-black
oppression there's no systemic racism
there's no anti-woman misogyny
patriarchy it's all you know that is a
fantasy of the lives because of that
they have to invent it this is what
you're seeing right now at BYU Brigham
Young University you may have heard of
this story I didn't even report on it
because I knew it was bogus from the
beginning but the headlines
for weeks now have been
that there was a racist incident during
a Brigham Young
volleyball game it was Duke versus
Brigham Young
and the Duke volleyball player Rachel
Richardson claimed that BYU fans
yelled racial slurs at her during the
game
BYU that's that's the Mormon University
Mormons probably the nicest and most
polite people who have ever walked the
face of the Earth they're apparently
screaming yelling racial slurs so the
minute I saw that I said nope that
didn't happen
there's just no way I would bet I would
bet probably my life savings that that
didn't happen at all nothing even
resembling that happened
then the day after the game this Duke
player's godmother Lisa Pamplin who's a
lib politician who is running for number
five judge of Tarrant County Criminal
Court tweeted Out quote my goddaughter
is the only black starter for Duke's
volleyball team while playing yesterday
she was called a and the n-word you're
not even allowed to say the word that's
that's how systemically racist America
is against black people there's there's
only one word in the entire English
language you are not allowed to say
right now and it's the word that would
be offensive to black people and she was
called that word for every time she
served
uh then in comes LeBron James of course
LeBron James one of the wealthiest most
privileged people in America who says
black man can't walk outside their door
without being hunted down by racist
police so LeBron James of course not a
whole lot going on in between those
years he decides to chime in he believes
the thing Hook Line and Sinker he says
Lisa Pamplin you tell your goddaughter
to Stand Tall be proud and continue to
be black we're a Brotherhood and
Sisterhood we have her back this is not
Sports
and then Richardson herself chimed in
said Friday night in our match against
Brigham Young my fellow African-American
teammates and I were targeted and
racially racially heckled throughout the
entirety of the match the slurs and
comments grew into threats okay which
caused us to feel unsafe so hold on
initially it was we were called names
then it was we were called the n-word
then it was we were directly threatened
not just me by the way my whole all the
black players even though apparently I
thought she was the only black player
whatever
as a result of this
uh South Carolina Women's Basketball
team decided to cancel its home and home
series with Brigham Young there was a
national outcry you know because of how
systemically racist America is everyone
just starts to cancel BYU because
because to even have this slight
insinuation that you might be in any way
racist against black people it will
destroy your entire life
and then BYU does an investigation
and finds
zero evidence that anything like this
took place
it never happened
all of the cultural forces in America
are pressuring BYU
to find any evidence of this
and and BYU couldn't
because it obviously didn't happen of
course
of course because none of these things
are real they're always hoaxes it's you
your reaction
two headlines about this is the most
interesting thing about the stories I
don't mean you you're if you're
listening to the show you're very
sensible people but I mean Americans
generally I had a friend this is right
after Trump wins a friend of mine in La
very very liberal
he says Michael the racism the Ku Klux
Klan has been Unleashed in America I
said I don't think so I actually know a
lot of black people who voted for Trump
I don't really I don't really buy that
he says no Michael I don't Michael I was
driving down in West Hollywood and I saw
a sign and it it said black people not
wanted here I forget the exact wording
but there's something to the effect of
go away black people we don't like you
can you imagine Michael in West
Hollywood the forces of racism have been
Unleashed I said hey buddy buddy
repeat what you just said
in West Hollywood
which is the most liberal part of one of
the most liberal cities one of the most
liberal states
you're seeing the sign so either there
is explicit either the Ku Klux Klan is
all Libs
or it's a hoax it's not real
it was put up
by either a black person who is trying
to get some kind of uh victim status
or in West Hollywood more likely
probably just a liberal white person
who is trying to
pretend that there is this awful culture
of racism you know to engage in a lie
but the LIE tells a greater truth that's
what the libs always say when they get
caught in a lie
but I'm sure and that isolated incident
I don't know there was no not even any
reporting about this sign that my buddy
saw I I promise you that was a hoax but
in the way that I know that that was a
hoax is that they always are hoaxes okay
these kinds of incidents have been going
on especially on campuses like BYU but
on campuses around the country these
things have been going on for 50 years
now or more and they have been
increasing in frequency constantly over
the last five or six years really
beginning with the Trump administration
because the libs had this narrative to
sell that Trump is a big racist and the
conservatives or the Ku Klux Klan and so
because there was no evidence of that
they had to fabricate it the demand for
anti-black racism is very very high the
supply is very very small and so they
have to manufacture the supply that's
exactly what they did
BYU turns out the race the racial hate
incident was a total hoax
69. Cornell University Willard straight
Hall you have black power activists who
are demanding the creation of an
African-American studies Center
an African-American studies Department
African-American studies is a fake
academic discipline but in the 60s these
kind of critical theory disciplines were
cropping up everywhere and so these
activists at Cornell wanted one and they
weren't going to get one because it's a
fake academic discipline so then what do
you know a burning cross shows up in
front of one of the black groups on
campus
and as a result of this there's a a
major incident you have black power
activists with guns holding people
hostage on campus and as a result the
university caves and creates the afam
studies department now the most curious
thing about this whole incident
is they never found out who put up that
burning cross
they never found any of those Ku Klux
klansmen on campus
in fact
they found a lot of evidence
that the black power activists burned
the cross themselves of course why
wouldn't they by by feigning victimhood
they got everything that they wanted
obviously Jesse smelly that's the
greatest example you got this basically
unknown actor from a show that pretty
much nobody watched walking around
Chicago downtown Chicago a city that had
been governed by Libs for almost 100
years at that point exclusively by lips
by one of the most notorious Democrat
machines and then it just so happens
that there were two
klansmen Maga hat wearing men out on the
street looking for this obscure actor
and carrying rope to to Lynch him
wearing the Maga hats and then Jesse
Smollett fought them off while holding a
Subway sandwich it never made any sense
half of the country believed it more
than half the country believed smile
even in the most ridiculous version of
this
that's the power of the narrative
2016. uh three black students in at
Oberlin College
accused a bakery and liquor store owner
of of racially profiling them
discriminating against them major major
incident Oberlin cuts the contract
totally defames this poor little Bakery
and it turns out now the kids were lying
they were trying to rob the store they
were trying to steal booze they
completely made it up and everyone
bought into it hook line and sinker
except for those of us who know that all
every single one of these incidents is a
hoax unfortunately now in court the
court when presented with all this
evidence actually uh found in favor of
the bakery but but too little too late
the baker actually ended up dying and
Oberlin still hasn't totally paid them
out
what about 2016 that same year Bowling
Green State University there was
allegedly an incident of a rock hurling
white Trump supporters
throwing these these rocks at a black
student the only evidence of racism or
violence that investigators could find
was a trove of text messages from the
black student who had concocted this
story the student had sent her her
boyfriend texts disparaging white people
and wishing death upon Trump supporters
and saying that she wished we would all
get AIDS okay the 2017 Saint Olaf
College in Minnesota a black student
left a racist threat on her own car
there was an oh here's a threat the
Clans going through Minnesota no she
wrote it herself 2017.
five black Air Force Academy Cadets
found racial slurs on their doors oh no
the clan is active at the Air Force
right no turns out investigation proved
they wrote the threats themselves and
the slurs themselves 2018 a black
student at Goucher College found uh in
in a dorm room bathroom I'm gonna kill
all n-words big uproar here we go the
clan is back the reasonable people knew
this was obviously fake and it turns out
yes the kid wrote the slur himself and
the irony of it is I guess the kid is
technically black if you look at a
picture of him he doesn't look black at
all you wouldn't know even know that he
was black so even the idea that he would
have been targeted is completely
preposterous
he doesn't not that he wouldn't have
been targeted anyway because this stuff
doesn't exist because it's all made up
because it's all it has to be fabricated
for the demand so why how does this
happen
it happens because of the power of the
narrative
in face of all the evidence and it's not
just that the libs buy into this stuff
the conservatives buy into it too down
in South Carolina there is a pro-life
bill that there are South Carolina
Republicans were trying to pass and it
just got shot down and it got shot down
largely because of defections by squish
Republicans in South Carolina five
Republicans Senate Republicans led by
GOP Senator Tom Davis filibuster the
abortion ban That was supposed to pass
on Thursday he was joined by three women
one other guy three women and here's
what one of the women said this was
Senator hen
I'm sorry Senator sen in South Carolina
she said we ladies are about to suffer a
setback at the hands of a lot of white
males in here but we're going to live to
fight another day the white males have
lost two we've been here for two days
and two nights and we're basically back
to the same bill we passed a year ago
and the Supreme Court has taken off the
table temporarily here's to Hope and
ladies
even the Republicans buy into this kind
of language the white males are the
worst
that the white males are the worst
people in the world
one time I was I was in Washington DC
and there was a group of black
nationalists called that Black Hebrew
Israelites they're the same guys that
were screaming slurs at the Covington
kid with the Maga hat outside of the uh
Lincoln Memorial the one where the crazy
Indian man started banging a drum in his
face and somehow the whole country
turned on the kid turned on the kid
because he's a white male and so I was I
was in front of this group in DC and
there was a kind of frivolous young
white girl uh there
and the uh
the the guy was yelling all sorts of
awful things about her and white people
in general and her reaction was
priceless it told me everything I needed
to know about the state of racial
political narratives she said hey stop
it that's not why are you yelling at me
I am a woman I've been oppressed by the
white men too
yeah you look real oppressed lady you
look real in your North Face with your
pumpkin spice latte oh I almost forgot
my son I got my nice little sign here
If Loving pumpkin spice Is Wrong I Don't
Want to Be Right so she's there I think
we actually may have been
outside of a coffee shop maybe a
Starbucks I don't I don't remember the
specific details but we're there and
this woman yells and I said lady you're
not
no the ant the answer to this ridiculous
narrative from this group that is
claiming all sorts of nonsense is not to
try to join their side to say no no I'm
also oppressed I well yeah all those
white men are terrible don't go after me
go up go after them
the answer is to knock down the whole
narrative I think the only the only way
we're going to get around this we need a
we need a major Nationwide political
campaign that says white guys are people
too
it says white white guys aren't the
worst people in the world
white guys aren't universally evil okay
that I don't know if you if you were to
have such a campaign it would probably
be called racist
and sexist you can't do it
the the libs have concocted this
narrative that white people are the
worst so anything white people do is bad
we talked about this last week with with
when white people moved neighborhoods if
white people move into a minority
neighborhood that's bad because that's
gentrification they're bad for doing
that but if white people move out of a
minority neighborhood that's bad that's
white flight and they're bad for doing
it so there's just nothing they can do
that's right and so maybe what that
tells you is just that the narrative is
unjust
okay
it's ju it is the libs creating an enemy
creating a scapegoat of people unjustly
and then leaving no limit to what can be
done to these people discriminate
against them according to the law I mean
think about what the libs are doing to
the Republicans now comparing us to
Al-Qaeda terrorists
okay there's no limit to that they're
accusing us of a capital offense
speaking of Education
uh Karine Jean-Pierre
is now on behalf of the Biden
Administration retconning covet because
what happened during covet was so
obviously
uh painful and pointless
all the masks and the lockdowns and you
can't go to school and you can't go to
church
it was so so awful and now the numbers
are in kids are much dumber than they
were before before the covet lockdowns
and so now what the Dems are doing is
they're saying hey actually remember
when the Republicans wanted to keep the
schools open and the Democrats
single-handedly shut them down and in
they did that because they're in the
pocket of the teachers union and and for
years they insisted on the school's
remaining shut down despite Republic
actually it was the opposite the
national assessment of educational
progress
is has this new testing that shows that
nine-year-olds lost ground in both math
and reading in pretty dramatic ways as a
result of the pandemic
um what is the president going to do
about it was the administration going to
do about this severe learning loss and
does the administration shoulder any
blame for not pushing schools to reopen
sooner
so let's step back to where we were not
too long ago when this President walked
into this Administration how mismanaged
the pandemic the response of the
pandemic was how 47 percent of schools
were in in less than six months our
schools went from 40 46 percent to to
open to nearly all of them being open to
full time that was the work of this
President and that was the work of
Democrats in spite of Republicans not
voting for The American Rescue plan
that was the work of Democrats despite
the Republicans
yeah no no no I know you think you
thought I know you thought that the
Republicans spent the whole time saying
reopen the schools reopen the schools
and the Democrats saying no we can't
because the teachers don't want to go
back to work but no
no it was the opposite
and a lot of people are going to believe
it this is the real advantage of
controlling the media and the tech
platforms is they can retcon this stuff
almost without any evidence left over
when I've gone back you know I've
mentioned this on the show before when
I've gone back to find the clips of Dr
fauci saying if you take the vaccine you
won't catch covid or Biden or wolinsky
saying the same thing when I've gone
back because they then obviously
contradict themselves very often those
clips are just gone you can't find them
I have to go back to my own show and
find the clips on my because at least I
I own that material find those clips
because otherwise they've been scrubbed
largely from the internet
that's what they're going to do on covid
they're going to say all the bad stuff
was Republicans all the good stuff was
Democrats even though it was completely
the opposite we cannot let them do that
if you've been thinking to yourself you
know it's been a while since we heard
from Candace Owens have I got news for
you
Candace is back from maternity leave in
a brand new eponymous daily wire plus
podcast
Candace Owens see the first show Candace
second show Candace Owens it's she's
she's growing she's expanding maybe
she'll have a middle name for the third
show she is going to fearlessly explore
the topics the media won't touch and
expose the corruption and hypocrisy in
news and politics best part is I love
this I've been begging her to do this
from the beginning five days a week so
it's not just this once a week thing we
are getting much more Candice Monday
through Friday you will not want to miss
her explosive first episode premieres
today at 3 P.M Central on daily wire
plus trust me when I say this is huge
check out Candace owens's podcast on
Apple podcast Spotify daily wear Plus or
wherever you listen to podcasts
I know that Republicans complain that
the schools were shut down during covid
and it is bad in terms of children's
overall progression and it's it's it was
completely needless from the standpoint
of medicine and Public Health
but there are some benefits namely your
children were not exposed for some
period of time to people like this
hold I and I love
my losses and I love just living loud
and proud and out and like to me this is
this is my art this is like my queer art
that I just exist colorfully every day
and
um I love a bold eye but here's one
place you should not wear a bold eye you
should not wear a bold eye when you're
going to hear Mike curato give a talk
about this book because if you do then
there's a strong chance that you might
cry and have like a Tammy Faye Baker
moment
yeah actually goes on and on about this
weird like kind of porny book that she's
promoting she's a school library she's I
don't know what bold eye means does that
mean weird rainbow glasses like the
rainbow hair or like the
like the rainbow everything that's a
school librarian who is peddling
pornography to your children and the
argument that she makes not even so much
in that video but in some of the writing
that she's published is is really
profound she says that
queer aesthetic
is a form of resistance
so you hear she's talking about her
glasses and her hair and her look and
her this and this picture book and the
images not so much the arguments not
even the rights just the aesthetic
is a form of resistance and she's
totally right
and conservatives answer to this
shouldn't just be like oh whatever who
cares yeah you want to wear your crazy
hair you look like a crazy person that's
not a big deal it's really just the
rights and the arguments and the law no
the conservative response to that should
be oh yeah you're right we should ban
that stuff
at least I'm not saying we pass a
federal law against stupid colored hair
I'm saying that we need to have storms
standards and norms and in places like
schools we need dress codes we always
had dress codes in places for all of
American public life and then I don't
know over the last five minutes we've
decided that we have a First Amendment
right to wear whatever we want in any
place we want that's not true when you
go into certain restaurants you need to
wear a jacket when you go to school
especially for most of American History
or history you needed to wear something
akin to a uniform
and you couldn't wear dresses that were
too short and you couldn't wear you
couldn't have your hair in some crazy
way and you couldn't have piercings and
tattoos everywhere
There are rules
to how to dress and those can be
enforced by institutions and we should
discourage
the weird crazy queer stuff she's
totally right
queer Aesthetics is a form of resistance
and we should oppose that
it is yet conservatives are really good
at talking about the truth
we're really good at saying no that's
not true that's false boom debunked
owned facts and logic we're really good
at that
we're okay at talking about the good not
all conservatives are not all
right-wingers some people don't want to
talk about the good they say well you do
you all do me we'll do whatever we want
that's true you're good might be my bad
whatever you know some nonsense but
generally conservatives have been
historically pretty good at saying no
there is such a thing as good and bad
and we should be moral and not be
vicious okay but conservatives are not
so great at talking about that third
transcendental of being Beauty
when we're talking about the
transcendentals we're talking about the
good the true and the beautiful that's
what we're supposed to pursue the good
the true and the Beautiful
and the Beautiful is really important
here too Aesthetics is really important
here too a man who is considered one of
the foundational conservative
philosophers Edmund Burke was an
aesthetic philosopher one of the most
prominent conservative philosophers
until he died a few years ago Roger
scrutin was in many ways an aesthetic
philosopher Beauty matters okay the way
we look
matters because we're sensible beings
right we we perceive things about the
world and it affects the way that we
live
this is this is why modern architecture
is such a big problem it's why
right-wing political movements have
taken an issue with modern architecture
and Modern Art going back to Max norda
writing the book to generacion on on the
unpleasant turn toward ugliness in
Modern Art
and that's a big problem for us we need
we conservatives have the confidence
most of the time some of the time at
least to say no that's not true that's
false you're not really a woman you're a
man
when we're going to insist on that we're
like pretty good at that and we're okay
but not that not great at saying No this
is good and this is bad and we should do
the good thing not the bad thing we need
to get better at that but we're just
abysmal it's you know this is beautiful
that's ugly do the beautiful thing
Donald Trump it was my favorite
executive order he ever signed it had no
teeth it went nowhere Biden rescinded it
immediately but it was the make Federal
Beauty make Federal buildings beautiful
again act they said look we have these
beautiful old buildings in Washington DC
then we have this modern new trash
that's so ugly and it makes you ashamed
to be in Washington DC let's get rid of
that stuff and make the new federal
buildings neoclassical and beautiful
again
let's do that and let's reinstitute some
dress codes
it's going to be really hard there was
there was a case about this Harris
Funeral Home case versus equal
employment opportunity commission went
up to the Supreme Court and it was about
a confused man who worked in a funeral
home who thought that he was a woman and
he insisted on wearing a dress and the
owner of the funeral home said look man
this is people are grieving they're
really fragile and vulnerable when they
come here and this is not the place for
you to make some bizarre perverted
political statement about how you're
really a woman that's not what these
people are here for it's distracting
it's real when you're working at a
funeral home it's about The Grieving
families okay and stop making it about
you you can't wear the dress put on
pants like an adult like a man and then
when you go home if you want to go we're
dragged to some CD Club at night be my
guest but not while you work here and
the confused man sued and he won
unfortunately
he won the case and so now we're not
allowed to enforce these things it's
very important for conservatives to dig
back in on this issue and just stop
seeding the ground here you think it's a
you think it's a little thing
how we dress what we wear what we look
like
but it
it affects the whole it truly affects
the way we view the world because it
affects everything that we see speaking
of dumb Court decisions a South Carolina
judge has just ruled that uh capital
punishment specifically by
the electric chair or firing squad is
unconstitutional
and how's that
this judge Jocelyn Newman
ruled that this style of executions
inflicted cruel and unusual punishment
this nullifying a state law passed last
year that forced death row inmates to
pick between one of those two methods
with electrocution as the default
procedure
so it's obviously not cruel and unusual
punishment
it's not it's certainly not unusual
right it's that's been a punishment for
many many years many many decades or
centuries even in some cases and so at
firing squad imagine how far back that
goes so it's obviously not unusual and I
don't think it's cruel
in fact I think those are some of the
more Humane ways to be executed
so that that's BS then she makes one
more claim she says well uh the the
electric chair law and the firing squad
law ignore advances in scientific
research and evolving standards of
humanity and decency and I think first
of all do you think we have evolving
standards of decency here do you think
they're evolving or devolving because I
think we're transiting the kids right
now and I think that our public
officials are wearing a leather daddy
pentagram straps and leading around
other human beings like their Doggies by
a collar okay I think I think we're
killing 800 plus thousand babies per
year in America I don't think we have
any evolving standards of decency I
think we have devolving standards of
decency and we have expanding standards
of degeneracy So based on that I don't
know you should be able to do anything
you should be able to draw and quarter
People based on where our current
standards of decency are but furthermore
okay you're admitting we can have
standards good let's have standards
let's have standards when it comes to
transiting the kids let's have a
transgenderism generally let's have
standards when it comes to the weird
Pride parades and the people working for
the Biden Administration let's have
standards when it comes to our language
the kind of language that people use in
public and on TV let's have all sorts of
Standards no we're not allowed to have
that we're only allowed to
we're only allowed to Institute new
radical leftist standards which are evil
but we're not allowed to embrace good
traditional Christian standards
it's just a completely rigged game
there's no argument here whatsoever
there's no principle here it gets right
back to what we're talking about at the
top of the show it's just power okay
it's just yeah you question election
yeah you're a terrorist get ready we're
gonna bring the firing squad to you but
oh yeah uh a mass murderer was sentenced
to death by firing squad no yeah that's
sorry
evolving standards of decency we need to
let that guy out on the street he's
probably a Democrat voter
you question the election you're a
terrorist I questioned the election I'm
defending our democracy
that's how it works that's how it works
okay and so we can either pull our hair
out and say where's the argument you
guys aren't being consistent you're
being Hypocrites yeah they know they're
being Hypocrites they don't care they
don't care okay the the conclusion for
us is we need to get power and we need
to we need to wield that power
and there's nothing anti-conservative
about that there's nothing anti-American
about there's nothing fascistic the word
fascism doesn't mean anything it's like
the word racism it's just a word that
they throw at us that has no meaning it
has been defined down into nothing so
just ignore it let it slide off you
like water off of wax okay
evolving standards of decency
it's insane
okay they want to kill you they want to
kill you Hillary Clinton said on it not
just Hillary Clinton the sitting
Democrat Senator Senator Warner
not just them the guy on CNN not just
the guy on CNN even out of the White
House they're saying you're fascists
you're terrorists you're committing a
capital offense your very existence
poses an existential threat to the
country
they're saying they want to kill you
okay and we're here are arguing over
well actually do you think that the
statute really and the spirit of the law
allows us to get rid of drag queens
forever give me a break wield some power
grow a spine good grief we're allowed to
grow all sorts of other appendages these
days in the transgender culture how
about we grow a spine that would be nice
maybe a couple other appendages too
would be good the rest of the show is
continuing now you do not want to miss
it if you're not a member click on that
link in the description and join us this
is music Monday baby we are going to be
listening to a new song that the
producers have picked out
I will give you my expert artistic
analysis you know that I'm hippity
hoppity you know I'm cool with the Jive
I'm Wonder Mike I've come to say hello
to the black the white the red and the
brown the purple and yellow But first
you got to head on over to that member
block we will be right there
[Music]
foreign